Let's consider a two
dimensional motion.
Suppose we have something
like projectile motion.
And we have an object moving.
Let's now describe how we
can describe this motion
with vectors.
So the first thing
we always want
to do, and let's remind
ourselves of the steps,
is we want to choose
a coordinate system.
Now what does a coordinate
system consist of?
It consists of an origin.
It consists of two axes.
In this case, we'll identify
the positive direction
for each axis as
plus x and plus y.
And at every single
point in space--
so if we had any arbitrary point
P here-- let's call this P1.
We have a choice of unit
vectors, i-hat 1 and j-hat 1.
Now, what makes
Cartesian coordinates
unique is that no matter
what point we're at,
the unit vectors
are all the same.
So we could erase
all these indices
for that particular
point and just
have an abstract set of unit
vectors, i-hat and j-hat.
Now normally what we'll do
is we'll just put those off
to the side.
So in our Cartesian
coordinates, we now
want to define the
position vector.
And the position
vector is a vector
from the origin to
where the object is.
So we'll write that
position vector.
We'll denote it by r of t.
Because as this object
moves along its trajectory
that position
vector is changing.
And we'll write
down r of t in terms
of two coordinate functions,
x of t and y of t.
And so our vector-- position
vector of the object r of t
is equal to x of t,
i-hat plus y of t, j-hat.
And one of our main
goals is to figure out
what these position functions
are for the motion of objects.
So this is how we
describe an object
in a Cartesian
coordinate system,
undergoing two
dimensional motion.
What we want to
analyze next is what
is the velocity of that object.